Speaker 1: I have never seen anything
like what I am about to play for you.
Kanye West went on something called drink champs
and delivered one of the most anti-Semitic
rants against the Jewish people that I have
ever seen in the sort of modern media era,
short of actual Nazis. And it's basically there.
Kanye West in controversy lately. I won't go
through the entire thing. He's a musical artist.
He was recently wearing White Lives Matter gear,
and then he went on the Tucker Carlson show
and said a whole bunch of stuff, including
anti-Semitic stuff, which got cut out, but which
we ultimately obtained and looked at last week.
Let's go through this. And I'm telling you. I
have I have not seen anything like this in the
modern era, sort of from overt white supremacists,
Nazis. Let's just jump right in and I will stop it
and talk about some of the things he says.
Speaker 2: We made the White Lives Matter.
TS And then when I put up the tweet, the Def
Con tweet, now here he released in the teeth
because he's Jewish. And I'm like, See,
this is my exact point that I'm making,
like Jewish people have on the black voice.
Speaker 1: White Jewish people have owned
the black voice. You know, it's interesting
because Kanye's recent thing over the last
few years has been black folks have no
one to blame but ourselves for slavery,
which is like a crazy thing to say. But
now, all of a sudden, he's actually found
something better. His first thing was Black
folks. We should just blame ourselves for
everything bad. Now he's actually saying,
Oh, you know, it's Jews. Let's blame Jews.
The truth is, Jewish folks have been one of
the premiere partners for black folks in the
United States to demand and obtain quality right
self-determination. Jewish folks have been killed,
in fact, to defending and supporting black folks.
Remember the movie Mississippi Burning about the
murders of black rights activists in Mississippi?
Sometimes people see the names and they get
confused because the victims were James Chaney and
Andrew Goodman and Michael Schwerner. And people
will look at that and say, Goodman and Schwerner,
though, those aren't exactly typical black names.
That's right. They were Jewish men from New
York City because the Jewish activists were
so intertwined with the civil rights movement.
The history is so intertwined. Kanye is way off
track. Now let's continue.
Speaker 2: What is to us
wearing a Ralph Lauren shirt.
Speaker 1: Okay. Ralph Lauren shirts.
So I realize that for me, all this stuff, I'm
familiar with every one of these things. But for
a lot of people, they don't know it. Ralph Lauren,
what do you mean? Why, Ralph Lauren? Ralph Lauren,
the designer was born Ralph Lifshitz, a Jewish
guy from New York City. So Connor says wearing
Ralph Lauren, it's another way in which Jews are
controlling us. Well, why not Tommy Hilfiger? I
mean, black folks like other people also wear
Tommy Hilfiger. Well, Tommy Hilfiger is Jewish,
so it's not interesting to Kanye. Ralph
Lauren is Jewish. So that is more interesting.
Speaker 2: Or as all of us being signed to
a record label or having a Jewish manager
or be assigned to a Jewish basketball team.
Speaker 1: What is a Jewish basketball team?
He doesn't mean an Israeli. I mean, there's an
Israeli professional basketball league. That's
not what he means. Does he mean a team where the
owner is Jewish or the general manager or what is
a Jewish basketball team? And, you know, there
is this for people who care about this stuff,
there is a very important historical story about
how Jews were pushed into certain professions.
There were all sorts of industries in which
Jews were just not allowed to participate. And
what happened was there was a period where the
industry's Jews were allowed to participate in
were the ones where in the sort of learning and
training could kind of happen on your own, like a
bunch of a bunch of Jews not allowed to do a whole
bunch of other stuff they could get together and
talk about, you know, whatever is it the law,
is it whatever. And so the very discrimination
against Jews created an environment in which
Jews were pushed towards certain industries.
The conspiracy to control those industries is
where it gets completely anti-Semitic. But there
is a discrimination history that talks about and
explains why you saw Jews push towards certain
industries. Anyway, this stuff is really nuts.
Speaker 2: Doing a movie on a Jewish
platform like Disney.
Speaker 1: Okay. What
is a Jewish platform like Disney? Walt Disney
was not only not Jewish, he had a reputation
for being very anti-Semitic. Walt Disney. So I
don't know how it's now a Jewish platform like
the current president of Disney is Bob Chapek.
Maybe he's Jewish. I don't know. I don't know
whether Kanye knows that. It's it's really nuts.
Speaker 2: And we understand it's like I respect
what the Jew Jewish people have done and what have
they done. They brought their people together. You
know, they came into money through the lawyers.
Oh, boy, oh, boy. Went after Wall Street went.
Speaker 1: What does that mean after Wall Street.
Speaker 2: When all of the like the Catholics,
they wouldn't they wouldn't divorce people.
Speaker 1: So that's truly bonkers.
Jewish lawyers came in to money by
divorcing people when the Catholics
wouldn't. I found no evidence of that.
Speaker 2: So the Jewish lawyers came
and they were willing to divorce people. That's
when they first came into it. Money. So like,
say, with me and J with our culture, with
the with the darker Jews, first of all,
because you got it happens when anybody starts
talking deep. Okay, here you get with the dark
with the dark ages, the 12 lost tribes of Israel.
Speaker 1: So remember I explained this last week,
this is the black Israelite stuff. Black
Israelites are a group that believe they are truly
the Jews. It's often a very racist set of beliefs.
Speaker 2: We are because we Jewish. Also,
we're from Africa. Also, we have blood of Christ.
Speaker 1: So now if you're confused by that last
line, it's bonkers. I won't even get into it.
Speaker 2: You're not just black. We are Jew,
just like the Jewish people. And now we're
coming into money. But the main thing is I
got to drink the dew, say, over the Hennessy
as the first step to us coming together,
like how the Jewish people came together. But we
couldn't even talk about. I remember Ben Horowitz,
call me after four, four, four said, I don't
know about J giving up business, Jewish
business secrets and secrets. Who is okay, Ben?
Speaker 1: Ben Horowitz. I know. I mean, listen,
there's no evidence that that happened. I guess
it's hard to comment on something so insane.
Speaker 2: About building up
the properties and stuff like
that. Yeah, these secrets. Can't they not fit?
Speaker 1: What he's arguing is that Ben Horowitz,
who's a venture capitalist and Jewish,
presumably because his last name is Horowitz,
I'm assuming he's saying he called up Jay-Z when
Jay-Z was starting, I guess, to make investments
in real estate. I assume by Jay he means Jay-Z and
told him that's a Jewish business secret. Right.
Buying real estate. That's a that's a secret.
I have never seen anything like this. I have
never seen anything like this. And you can, of
course, say, oh, it's simply mental illness. Well,
sure. I mean, he sounds. Mentally ill in a lot
of different ways. But he has become fixated with
Jews in a way that is reminiscent of the worst of
the worst of the worst to anti-Semites. We will
have that clip on our Instagram at David Pakman
show. Hard to find a true word in that segment.